so I like to
introduce feel to Lowe's I might okay
he will be talking about how to build
SQL based data warehouse for a trillion
rows in Python he's the principal
engineer at Admiral and he's originally
from Finland right and he's actually the
original creative or disco so let's
welcome bill to Lowe's thanks thank you
can you hear me in the back yes I guess
like it seems to be working
yes I'm a little less I work at a droll
I'm actually leading our internal
analytics team kind of that's
responsible for building the platform do
you analyze all the data we have so I
was thinking actually I just realized
well actually let me like start with one
question so has any of you seen the kind
of the presentation that I gave at the
kind of the Python meetup last September
I mean it's a light online as well yeah
like okay at least one well two people
okay three so yeah I mean like I could
have used the old slides so I just
realize Italy anyway so so yeah I mean
I'm at the ad roll I'm doing analytics
and like yeah it's just like wanted to
tell you I've worried about ad rolls so
what we do is that the if you ever have
let's say like like you went to a
website to buy a like a pair of sneakers
or like headphones so whatever and then
you see those like annoying ads follow
you in Facebook and like any site like
in Google advertising networks that's
basically us so so so that's what we do
so I mean it's called retargeting and
the interesting fact is that actually um
the whole machinery that actually powers
advertising these days on the web and
actually mobile and whatever it's
actually it's probably kind of one of
the most complex machines that has been
ever built by the humankind and then not
many people actually know about it so
it's actually super super fascinating
technically even though I mean like you
might be annoyed by by those ads that
that follow you but if you think about
it's actually it's actually amazing that
how do they actually know that that I
just went to that website and like how
do they know that actually that's
exactly what I was looking for and and
the reason of course why why the system
is so intelligent is that there's like
lots of money involved so I mean they're
companies like this one
like and Google and like AdRoll who were
actually it spent tons of time and and
like really smart people in actually
solving this question so basically how
it works just like to tell you could
quickly stand up so like if you're a
customer of federal you add the small
piece of JavaScript to your website that
basically every time you visit this page
basically since as a request with the
cookie store we assign you a cookie so
we know that okay you were like looking
at this side basically the same thing as
what google analytics and other
analytics products do and you were
looking at this page and this is your
identity based on the cookie and so
forth and then the interesting part is
that like we actually partner with like
many third party like me advertising
networks like Facebook and Google and so
forth and then when like let's say you
go to Facebook Facebook actually sends
us a request containing that cookie or
your identity and like within 100
milliseconds we have to decide how much
we want to bid on this impression and
that's actually the interesting thing is
that well I mean first it's interesting
like real time low latency problem and
second it's of course all about data
it's totally it's a purely like a
machine learning problem that like
basically you want to build a model that
estimates the value of the customer or
these eyeballs at this like point of
time given this advertiser I know
everything I mean like as as well as
possible so it's extremely fascinating
and of course as you can imagine I mean
the volume is huge we are getting
hundreds of thousands requests per
second and that's the first fraction of
like well let's say what what Facebook
and Google are handling so this talk is
about like the analytics system that
that we have built that basically powers
all our internal analytics and well it's
this low latency it's in the memory it's
actually fully SQL compliant which is
kind of a big thing and and yeah it's
actually really being used seriously so
it's really not the toy product and why
you should be interested is that
actually it's like mostly the core parts
are written in Python so now I mean like
if like I was like actually sitting
there in the audience and I saw this
slide I would probably think that either
the guy is crazy or they don't have lots
of data since I mean really I mean you
don't do like big data really I mean or
especially like data warehouses in
Python well unfortunately I think it's
the former so I mean it's definitely on
the crazy category since we do have lots
of data so like I mentioned I mean the
volume is really remarkable I mean
like basic we are storing each bit
request every time we get an opportunity
to show an impression even though we
might not be showing an impression we
load that information also of course
like every time you click an ad every
time you end up buying something we
collect all the data so it ends up being
like really really kind of tons of data
every day so 50 terabytes 80 billion
events and the interesting thing about
our system is that it's append-only we
basically never delete any any useful
data of course like except what's
required by by whatever like privacy
compliance and and it's very granular so
of course it's all about understanding
very specific segments of users very
specific groups of advertisers and how
they are behaving and that ends up being
a lot of data so the biggest data cube
that that has been built using daily
role at add role actually contains four
trillion log lines so I mean I guess the
kind of the title of the talk originally
was something like about billions of
data points unfortunately kind of weak
robbed a fast so I updated the title to
be trillion trillion rows in a data
warehouse so so that's that's kind of
interesting technically I just like want
to give you a brief overview how it
looks like at the high level like we
actually run everything using AWS it
works pretty well for us we store all
the raw data in Amazon s3 which is the
storage service it's actually the log
the log files per se are actually it
really sits like in a very like a simple
almost like a CSV like format which is
like very extremely robust and and then
we use MapReduce to do some like
pre-processing for the log files just
like basically the stuff that like
MapReduce is meant for and then we have
this like a custom data back-end that
like serves all the real-time requests
that we are getting from everybody using
using the kind of this analytics
platform and the thing is that like yeah
they're like a handful of machines
powering it but this is not about like
having having a hugely distributed
massive system with like a data or like
actually like a physical warehouse like
a full of full of servers but actually
something quite the opposite so as you
will hear soon the after it's like
that's the back-end part that I showed
you this is actually the front-end part
and this is actually the really the part
that matters to the business and like
for the actual use of the system
one of the biggest benefits of actually
using sequel proper like really being
fully sequel compliant is that you can
use all the existing tools that have
been built that have been built with
like for bi and like data visualization
and whatnot so work for instance we are
using this commercial tool called
tableau it's like pretty pretty slick
like pretty visual way of like slicing
and dicing data building dashboards and
reports but I mean of course it's just
like one of the tools that you could be
using I mean given that actually the
system is powered by Postgres so that's
actually one of the things I mean it's
kind of a a bit annoying that like these
days you see like see these systems that
kind of say that they do see equal and
like what they mean by see equal is that
they have select in all uppercase but
that's exactly not sequel I mean what
sequel it's actually like 400 pages of
like ANSI standard like specifying
extremely kind of a minute details of
like what you should do in different
situations and like no one interred like
I say in mind would actually implement
something like that from scratch so we
are just like piggybacking on on
Postgres and how we do that is that we
use this amazing project called
multi-core and thanks to Postgres
post-course is super awesome in actually
in the way that like it exposes this
interface called foreign data wrapper
that basically allows you to map any
external data source as like a normal
relational table in inside your like a
database so basically to the user it
sees its like seems that you are just
using a normal relational database you
have a normal relation on table you can
do any joints I mean you can do full
sequel but actually what happens
internally is that like when post per
sees that you are accessing this table
it sends well I mean there's an API it
actually calls a function that you have
defined that basically says that okay
give me these columns I mean like that
actually has to satisfy these where
clauses and stuff like that and
multi-core internist is approach that
written in Python that provides a simple
like a Python binding for the C API so
basically it's just a matter of like
defining like two methods in in a Python
class and you have a fully functioning
relational table so it's absolutely
amazing and you should definitely check
it out so it's at multi corner toric so
I mean I don't actually know why people
are not using it more often because it
says so like super simple way in
exposing any any kind of a data source
is due to like a proper sequel database
and then like actually the multi-core in
our case it actually takes takes the
request and then it actually sends it to
our like a master server or like one of
them which then in turn this abuse it I
trust the occurs multiple course and
then like the the kind of the machines
then in turn use like this like nice
compiler called number to compile T kind
of that queries to efficient machine
code but I mean like I'll go actually in
the details later so but I mean like
that maybe the most interesting question
is that like okay so why do things in
this way in the first place so I mean
like when I say that the eyes like a low
latency in memory sequel compliant data
warehouse I mean that's kind of boring
since that's like what many companies
have been doing for a long time also
it's something that like many new
companies claim to be doing and and like
you may ask that okay so what's the
point of like reinvent the wheel kind of
and of course the standard answer is
always like what everybody say that yeah
well I mean like kind of a day none of
this existing solutions like actually
fulfill our needs and like they didn't
do this and they didn't do that and
actually that's true in our case as well
the they're like viewed like specific
like get requirements that we have and
of course like we are doing lots of like
meshing learning as well and like
automated data mining so yeah it's kind
of hard to use but actually the real
reason is it's also I mean there's like
a deeper technical reason that I really
want to talk about and really the
background is that actually when you are
doing purely analytics meaning that most
of the data is immutable since the
history doesn't change actually querying
like turbines or even petabytes of data
is super easy so I mean this is I mean
this is kind of like exactly the
opposite what you oftentimes hear people
saying and they're they're they kind of
the crucial difference is that like this
is not like a like a normal like like a
transactional database where you kind of
a changed or like a key value store even
like a center out react where you can
change anything at any point of time and
then you get these super hard problems
and actually keeping data consistent or
at least eventually consistent and all
that stuff but this is all about just
like accessing like data that doesn't
change ever and that's really easy since
what you can do is that you can take a
client any kind of client in pretend in
Python and this client is just like a
sending queries to the back-end system
and like what you can do in the backend
side is that like you set up a server
you run let's say Postgres it can be
radius whatever and you'd like to take
let's say some like a decent amount of
light like 10 million rows
and you dump it in a database and of
course I mean this part like works
really pretty well I mean you have a
client then like you send a sequel query
to a database and post Chris can handle
like 10 million rows or whatever is the
number pretty well now of course the
question is about scalability so how do
you make this scale well I mean quite
simply you add another machine so now
you can add all twenty million rows you
add another machine you can handle 30
million rows you had like 45 and like
how many other machines you need I mean
like let's say you need like to handle a
million rows and you can only handle 10
million rows per machine decently well I
mean what you do is just add 100
machines and there you go or like
whatever arbitrary number and well I
mean this is something that used to be
possible only for big companies with
tons of capacity but now it easy to I
mean like you can do it by yourself so
what I'm saying is that actually like
this is not an engineering issue I mean
this is not like a super awesome thing
that like our engineers built it's
something very special per se I mean
it's an operational issue that like when
you start having hundreds of machines or
even tens of machines you have to keep
the whole system running you have to
make sure that like there are no network
partitioning and like all the machines
operating how the performance is about
equal is same and like if machines go
down you have to have a system to kind
of launch a new machine and it's
operationally it's a pain in the ass I
mean it's like not like a super hard
problem otherwise and of course what
people end up doing is that like you
kind of want to solve that question like
like as it's like a software thing
anyway so you build like a system like a
zookeeper or something to kind of keep
track off your cluster and like like
whatnot but I mean basically it's an
operational issue that you are solving
and not an analytic issue and now the
second problem is that actually um most
of that like work is wasted anyways the
problem is that like actually like if
you have like typical log lines like
this that like let you have like this
like a chase on events most of the data
is redundant so I mean you have like in
this case you have the like the field
names some like the values are repeating
and and like actually in this case I
mean you have about like a 3 kilo bits
of data and but only 400 bits of
information and note by the way that
it's not like some like a vague Vasily
definition of information that you hear
at some booth at strata conference but
it's really like an information
theoretical entropy so actually if you
apply lossless compression I mean that's
the definition of information
that's actually what what matters and
says to motivate this point I mean this
is like a small benchmark that I ran so
let's assume that like you have like
some amount of information I guess like
it was like a vector of like 10,000
elements and if you apply it like
perfect encoding for this piece of data
you would have like let's say the
performance is a ten note note that the
y-axis is at the logarithmic scale
now imagine that like actually instead
of having the perfect encoding it's
actually like JSON so you have like a
field names here and there may be like
64 characters or something like that
actually like processing the day that
becomes like 100 times slower and now
imagine that like this was actually like
MapReduce or something were you actually
doing this like a stance over massive
amounts of data that actually it's not
relevant to your question and like you
are adding like 32 kilobytes of
information or additional kind of stuff
that's not needed there and suddenly the
problem is the kind of the results are
produced like 10,000 times slower now
8,000 times slower it completely the
original one
so well I mean it's it's actually a big
issue since I mean the results are
exactly the same you are suspending
4,000 times more time producing the
results
well now you might say that may say that
well I mean like this is a Python
conference we all are using Python so I
mean kind of there's only so much we can
do you Python it's a high-level language
well I mean actually that's that's not
the case I mean if you are using things
like number me you can definitely kind
of fit like optimize things for it for
like high efficiency well and that's the
thing I mean like people do care about
latency people do care about like how
long it will take to get to results and
really I mean like for most of the
analytics the bottle is bottleneck is
actually the CPU true but how much data
you can push through the CPU and now the
problem is that like the CPU is care
only about the actual data and not the
information or entropy so it's it's all
about how much how much actually useful
work you are doing per time unit and now
if you want to make things faster you
have basically two choices given that
like the CPU to boot is really like
physically limited it's the hardware
limitation what you can do is that you'd
reduce the amount of data that you
handle per CPU so there what you can do
is that you can either increase the
number of CPUs and we are kind of back
to the starting point with that like
operational headache or
you can increase information density and
get rid of that waste and that's of
course like easier said than done I mean
it's a developer headache how do you
actually make that happen
but I mean the end result is that like
well things such as faster so this is
like a classical memory hierarchy
motivation that you see often times so
this is the same thing how much time it
Purdue it takes to produce the same
results given different amounts of of
redundant data or like whatever like
like wasted wasted like like encoding
they're there in your in your like in
your data set so basically what you see
there is that on the x-axis is the size
of the data how much data you are
actually trying to process and on the
y-axis you have that like how many how
many operations you are doing per second
and now as long as you can fit the full
data set in question or lower whatever
you need like the kind of the resident
set to answer the query you can fit it
in l3 cache which in this case happens
to be like 23 megabytes on this machine
I mean you can actually really like
reach the peak performance like when it
comes to integer operations immediately
when you go out the cache and like you
have whatever liming into your data
doesn't fit in the cache anymore you
basically lose 40 percent of the
performance and if you are so very
unlucky that actually your data set
doesn't fit in your ram i mean basically
it's game over
so I mean line note by the way that like
in this case I mean it's not zero I mean
it's like still like 23 operations per
second very per microsecond but I mean
it's I mean as you can see I mean it's I
mean it's kind of pointless to talk
about low latency at that point and note
by the way this is not like a rusty old
spinning disk but I mean this is
actually a top notch SSD but it says
that like there's no competition when it
comes to cache so like point is that
like yeah I mean information density
makes sense and now again like
motivating that yeah I mean this is a
Python conference but actually this
should concern you you as well which is
that like what I mentioned about number
which is just like really nice like a
compiler for for numerical Python by the
continuum guys I made another small test
like comparing like really the pretty
much the kind of the most efficient C
program that you can imagine and then
the result that you get by just applying
that like one line of code say like
basically one decorator to a Python
function that tell us no but the compile
it down to machine code using LLVM
basically the difference is some like
system by 30% and interestingly by the
way I mean you can see that like number
performance a bit differently when the
data goes out the cache and like of
course I mean like when again I mean way
it goes out of RAM I mean like nothing
matters anymore
but also another way of putting this is
that um if you can reduce the basically
or if you can increase the information
density or if you can reduce the amount
of data you are producing or if you what
you are handling by 30 percent there's
no difference whether you use C or
Python like with known by this case
since I mean like anyway you gain so
much by by processing more useful
information per time unit so the point
is that like when people say that well I
mean like Python is slow or whatever
yeah that's kind of true and of course
actually yes I mean Python would be I
mean pure Python would be like a
thousand times slower by default but
well I mean given the right tools and
like I especially given the fact that
like you spend it look slightly more
time in actually designing your like a
encoding and designing your data layout
you gain so much that really I mean
nothing matters in comparation
so it this is like the whole point of
this talk is that like well I mean like
when when you want to kind of a deal
with large amounts of data that really
the thing you should be you should like
really think hard about this is the
information density how much like a
stuff you are like a basically
processing are like how much like
redundant information like you are like
pushing through the CPU since if you
care about low latency and like really I
mean you should since I mean it actually
makes a qualitative difference I mean
that's that's really the easiest easiest
way to get there of course the thing is
that um it takes more time it's kind of
well I mean depending on the person it
might be either fun or not so fun to
kind of it like think about that in the
beginning but I mean the point is that
like kind of it when you keep using the
system over time I mean like basically
you you win every day and that's a big
difference the operational stuff which
is quite the opposite so that you kind
of a pay that like operational cost
every day and like a second point is
that like I enough answering did the
original why question why AdRoll did
this like system like internally instead
of using something is that well I mean
like this like information density stuff
is really hard to outsource so so I mean
actually there's this like a kind of a
very deep like a theorem theorem and
like the result of the mathematical
information theory is that there is a
close I may actually busily like one to
one
relationship between the kind of the
probability and the code length so
basically did the better you are able to
predict your your data I mean the more
predictable it is the smaller the fewer
bits you need to encode the data so
basically this is kind of an interesting
intersection of like data science and
machine learning and engineering which
is that like if you happen to know your
data really well and you can build a
model that can predict the data
extremely well it also means that you
can apply extremely have in a very
efficient encoding for the data and it
which means that like you can build a
system that's like really super fast so
so that's that's kind of interesting
also I mean like of course like people
are always like saying that well I mean
you can't like use custom solutions or
or like you should be like leaving stuff
like these to people who know what
they're doing and maybe so but I mean
they're like few things that I think
that I actually working like you know
like you to make it easier like for
people to really kind of build like
purpose-built systems one of them is
that well I mean it's kind of important
so it's too important to be just
outsourced as a kind of a non-core
business question also it's easier these
days of course to develop software
that's also one of the key points of
this talk that like by using Python we
are able to build more complex
algorithms because it's not as painful
given an expressive language which then
allows you to actually build more
advanced solutions and then like when it
comes to actually keeping the system's
running well I mean like it's it's a
world of difference with with something
like AWS and and the old ways of working
where it's like just getting a server up
and running was actually a major major
pain so so yeah I mean there's like
really nothing wrong about like buying
an external solution and of course like
we are doing that all the time but the
thing is that like really I mean what
you're losing with that is the ability
to kind of optimize for your use case
obviously and it comes with a major
operational burden so so that's kind of
the thing that like you kind of gets
over an underestimate it that really I
mean like what it really takes like have
something like Hadoop or something like
Cassandra running with petabytes of data
like 24/7 and and so forth so basically
by reducing the number of moving
components by having more information
density I mean life's just become
simpler and cheaper so well I mean then
actually do the whole part of the
presentation
so I mean this is definitely I mean the
unfortunate fact is that the system that
we have built this not open-source so
unfortunately our concepts like it give
you like a like it like a github link to
the github repo and say the Tuolumne you
just like try it out by yourself but
even better I mean like I can tell you I
mean like how you can do the same thing
at home so it's it's really not that
hard so I mean like well I mean again I
mean the question is about information
density and like how you really focus on
making things fast
well really I mean if you really go back
to the fundamentals and ask yourself
that like what's the fastest operation
that possibly you could do when you get
rid of all the kind of the layers and
abstractions and and like whatever
frameworks you you have considered to
use I mean really I mean when the what
like really which is really not Turtles
all the way down but I mean like really
at the bottom level what's the fastest
operation it's really the single
instruction multiple data vector
operations on the on the CPU and then
like well I mean if that's the fastest
operation like what's the most efficient
way to like access data our store data
well obviously it's something like numpy
matrices or or just whatever way you
have to have like densely packed
integers or it may be even like floating
points in memory and of course in the
best case in the cache so I mean like we
kind of come to this like a really nice
conclusion that year kind of matrices
are fun and they are really suitable to
kind of a modern CPUs so I guess that's
really not surprising to anyone in this
audience well I mean what might be kind
of bit more surprising is that actually
like you can use something like this as
a as a back-end for a bi system so of
course like many of the talks that we
have been hearing in this conference
have been about like classical high
performance computing or like research
like stuff and like linear algebra and
whatnot and not so much about this like
like a boring reality of like running
like a business with 150 million dollars
in revenues but really it really can
boil down to the same reality that the
AI actually kind of a you can you can
like make make things happen with a
matrix so and that's what we are doing
it's like our system it's all about just
having a big matrix and well I mean like
how do you actually kind of get from
things like these to a matrix so I mean
that's kind of it like typical event
data what you are seeing so you have
some pretty homogeneous data of course I
mean you don't
have all the fields but imagine that
like you have this like a nice little
JSON message cheese you have some fields
with some love some names some values
and that's that's the raw data you are
getting Oh
I mean look obvious thing you can do I
mean just to make things slightly more
efficient is that like you can just get
rid of the field names I mean it's kind
of just like totally redundant I mean
that's like CSV basically not not to
complicate it and the next step after
this what you can do is that like you
can encode all these things as integers
so like you see I mean true/false I mean
like obviously you can have like 0 and 1
and that's an integer and like let's say
that like actually originally you had
like country is the middle field so well
I mean there's there's a finite number
of countries in the world maybe like 250
so yeah I mean you can have like numbers
between 1 and 250 and those are your
countries as integers and then finally
maybe there's the last column what is
that so that's the cost field so that's
obvious obviously an integer so you have
well I mean that's a matrix it's like 3
by 3 matrix and now actually in our case
if you actually take a little bit like
like a bird's eye view to the day that
the data looks like this so so those are
the same fields I mean and go in the
same way I mean it as integers but
that's like a tons of log lines what do
you see there interesting list at first
I mean it looks kind of sparse which is
that like we don't always have all the
fields set and then actually it's not
always first since I mean there's there
are things like timestamp or or maybe
there's some ID that we always set and
then stuff like that so it's kind of a
but it's like an interesting looking
matrix so that's that's a good starting
point so I mean still I mean the
question remains that like how do we
actually get from this sparse looking
matrix to a columnar database that
actually we can use the power tableau or
like whatever it bi you want to do well
I mean the first question of course I
mean like if you think sequel is that
like you want to run queries like that
so you're kind of like selecting
something that like satisfies certain
like a where clause and like maybe you
are aggregating over columns since like
that's what you dippity-do in analytics
so as you can imagine it's really not
that complicated using matrices so it's
basically a dot product between the
matrix and a vector that basically
defines it's like an index vector that
for each row like tell us that like
whether that particle like we're closest
is being status
so let's say they can't like the : value
thing there is that like a country
equals Sweden well you can have this
like a binary vector like that for each
log line tells you whether this slope
line is actually coming from Sweden and
now if ever anyone like I wanted to run
a query like that you could just as
easily take that like an index vector
that says if the line is coming around
Sweden and then you apply it to the
matrix and like them it's just a dot
product I mean you get the kind of the
sums for each column and that's your
result just like as common operation is
also that well I mean actually you don't
want to kind of have all the columns
let's imagine that you can have hundreds
of columns so I mean again I mean it
gets just like take a subset of columns
so how it happens is that well you have
another like a small matrix that were at
or a small vector where you actually
just have like zeros and ones like ones
for the columns you want to get included
and zeros which are not that necessary
and then then you have like this
diagonal matrix and they you take the
dot product and then again you can apply
the index vector and again I mean that's
that's how you get the result so I mean
it's it's really that easy and like yeah
I mean I've been there like few other
things you may want to worry about like
whatever like through PI's and I so
forth but that's that's that's kind of
it so I mean there's that's it now the
presentation is well I mean not so fast
I mean the problem is that if you have
tons of data and that's actually the
first thing I did and it actually works
nicely I mean you can like push it to
GPU and it's really pretty fast but the
problem is that if you imagine that like
you had a billion rows in the matrix
maybe 100 columns and like it's a sparse
matrix so only 10 percent of the of
these cells are actually filled well let
me know if there are like different ways
to encode the sparse matrix so you can
have like this like columnar of
representation so you have a 32-bit
colon ID and 32-bit value so it's like
64 bits per item the result is that the
matrix is like 600 gigabytes so you can
have a server like with 60 hundred
gigabytes of RAM I mean it's possible
but it's slightly inconvenient so it's
it's a bit on the large side so what can
you do so actually now kind of question
to the audience so if you had a block
like this I mean like a like a number
like or a well I mean um PI doesn't
support you like a sci-fi sparse matrix
and you dump it
disk and then you say I guess zzip and
then the file name so do you think that
it will be smaller than 600 gigabytes or
like is it exactly 600 so any idea so
I'm like and like why it might be
smaller if that's the case
that's that's well I mean kind of thick
: ID and it so you are not like storing
everything kind of with that like : ID
and value encoding anyways but yeah it
is it is of course parse and well I mean
like yeah I mean definitely the answer
is that it will be smaller and the
reason why it's smaller is that like
imagine that like in this case you have
100 columns well I mean like you are
using like 32 bits to encode that like
column Nydia even though in practice you
only need seven bits so I mean basically
for each column ID you are like wasting
how many is that like 25 bits so I mean
like gzip of course can take care of
that and like you have like just like a
tons of zeros in your data and like C's
it's just like compresses it away so so
yeah I mean that's really I mean the
point is that like again I mean going
back to the point that like you should
care about information density really I
mean like you are not doing a very good
job with this since I mean basically I'd
like one interesting result what I ended
up doing and I would I actually
recommend to everybody is that like real
men and real women actually did debug
their software using zzip so if you if
you see that you can compress your data
it sees if you are doing something wrong
so yeah I mean you you actually want to
rethink the encoding and this is just an
example of actual like a rose in our
data so I think that the kind of the
craft should be like other way around so
it's just like think that it's like
rotate it by 90 degrees so the red lines
are the base you logarithm of the values
in the data so that's kind of the
optimal the minimal number of bits you
would need in the perfect situation
the pink background represents the fact
that that like if you actually look at
the maximum value I mean it's kind of an
easy thing you can do I mean you can see
that well I mean the maximum value I
need to store is like 16,000 so yeah I
mean I can just use two bytes to store
each of the value store I guess in an
numpy yeah I mean you have something
like u2 or something like that as a d
type so so you can just use two bytes
per value but I mean the pink background
shows that like of course I mean like
you had still like wasting tons of space
because like most of the values actually
smaller than the whatever like or 65,000
for unsigned integers so one thing that
like we ended up doing is that actually
you can use this like a variable length
encoding for integers so that's
represented by the black line
so what it does is that like I mean you
could like really do it at the bit level
but that's that's kind of inconvenient
so you can do it at the byte level so by
default it uses 8 bytes I mean like one
bite
oh sorry 8 bits or 1 byte um when it can
and in those cases when it's not enough
it just like adds one more bite that
that's basically how utf-8 works as well
so so basically you see that those
spikes actually represent this cases
where we end up using as many bytes SD
as the original like max encoding and by
the way that's what typical columnar
database is do often times like Amazon
redshift and and it's it's nice but I
mean still rather wasteful so by doing
this I mean yeah I mean like you like
shades like 50% of the size of the
matrix so that's that's pretty
impressive now it's like like maybe to
300 gigabytes and like actually the
biggest machine in Amazon is like 200
240 for a gigabyte so you can like fit
the matrix in ram mode right now but I
just do it by doing this well the other
interesting thing what you can do is
that um still I mean like if you
compress that matrix it would still I
mean compressed using ZZZ it and the
reason actually for a deist like if you
if you look at the chart there like many
kind of a consecutive like consecutive
numbers that are the same so there is
like there are lots of regularities in
the data and the regularities might not
be always obvious at first but I mean
then maybe there are some like
transformations that you can apply like
basically let's say it's just like a
short the matrix by row I mean it's the
same information but you're just like a
sorting the sorting the matrix and like
like amazing what happens is this is all
this like patterns emerge and like
actually you see that well I mean like I
have tons of repetition in my data and
even more interestingly of course the
repetition happens at the column level I
mean you see that those kind of a nice
like straight lines I mean you can just
use something like run length encoding
quick to get rid of ten but like also I
mean there are like regularities that
the row level and like really the
interesting like the modeling question
is that like for instance what happens
with our data and like typically well I
mean like like like you're like a web
event data and overall is that um you
have lots of dependencies between
different columns say I mean like we
have a certain campaign that's only
running in Sweden which means that like
always in the campaign ID is this the
the the kind of the country country
field will be sweet and so it's it's
kind of always the same
and that's also another thing that you
can utilize you can kind of also kind of
utilize that fact to kind of get rid of
get rid of like those like redundancies
that you have by storing again and again
I mean the same information and there
are actually many other tricks that you
can do I mean like you can kind of a do
it like a crowd you Ellie I mean like
kind of start with the simple things I
mean like gradually see if there are
like other things that can be optimized
and just like Apple I different
different methods so like I mentioned I
mean like you can use run-length
encoding to get rid of those like
consecutive numbers you can use
dictionary encoding to get rid of like
if you had like at repetitive strings
you can use like a delta encoding if you
have like that like a sets of integers I
mean like what we actually do when we
have these like strings to rows
basically indices I mean like you could
use that like the bitmap index or or you
can use Delta encoding the kind of
encode the road row ID he said that
works quite nicely as well or then you
can get like a little bit fancier and
like really start thinking that like can
I actually like to predict the values
and like given the predictions you can
actually apply something like Huffman
coding to kind of come up with really
good like encoding scheme for your data
well now of course the kind of a thing
after you have gone through the whole
ordeal of like applying this like a
crazy different encoding sin' and stuff
the problem is that like you can't just
like use the numpy dot anymore I mean
it's like this like a horrible monster
data structure that you have created and
like there's no way that like you could
like and anyone could figure out what's
going on so the unfortunate fact is that
like you need now kind of a bunch of
custom code to actually kind of a decode
peek out the matrix on the fly when you
are like performing operations and this
is exactly what we do so basically what
happens in our system when someone like
a ghost it goes to post Christ and like
well actually let me let me show you
let's see if this works this is always
kind of dangerous to kind of a show a
live demo but I mean like on the left
hand side you actually have like one of
the servers like staying idle I told
everyone that don't touch the server now
and they don't think on the right-hand
side this is by the way this is just
like a normal like a piece equal and
like what you can do here is that like
well I mean I'm really I don't know if
this works but let's see
so we
you can like do use like some number of
events let's like just like a business
just like basically one of the columns
saying that like how many how many
events of this type we have from from
this like one like a nice data cube that
contains our RTP data so now you
actually see the Python process is
starting that actually do it processing
and that's the result let me actually
divide it by something like that number
so you can actually figure out what is
right so 1 + 12 0 is a trillion so it's
it's 40 point two trillion events so
actually what happened there is that
when you actually do this like queries
in the Postgres it actually um like I
mentioned I'm it uses foreign data
wrapper for the Postgres in forums
multi-core in that ok so these are the
columns that are being requested we like
have our custom like a wrapper for a
multi corn that like creates this
request that goes to the other server
which is hosting the data and this
server actually has a small well I mean
it has the process that actually manages
all this like a Python processes that we
have like one per core and and then like
these Python programs actually see that
okay so what's the exactly the thing
that the user is trying to do and
interestingly given the fact that is
unfortunately kind of complicated like
the encoding it's non-trivial it
actually generates this like a piece of
Python code that like looks actually
really pretty and readable and easy to
understand but luckily it's
automatically generated so you don't
mind but the kind of the key thing here
is that like it's actually has the cheat
which is the kind of the magical number
function that tells number that ok so
take this function and like compile and
optimize it using LLVM to the machine
code and that's actually the thing that
actually gets executed against the
densely encoded data and by the way the
key thing here is that like if you
wonder that like I mean like if you're
saying that well I mean used like sees
it for debugging I mean why not just
like I mean like do whatever everybody
does that like just compress their data
and that's it well the thing is that
like if I did that what would happen is
that like a first before I can do any
processing I would need to decompress
the data so first I would like to run
something like like unzip and like
decompress the matrix and then again I
mean I have this like a 600 gigabytes of
data that I have to push through the CPU
and just imagine how long long that
going to take so they're kind of the
benefit of actually devising coming up
with your own encoding is that you don't
have to decompress anything so I mean
the data is already exactly in the
format that like maximizes the
information density even exactly the
problems that you want to answer so I
mean again I mean like I said I mean
this is just just like a normal normal
seek well so I mean you can do all kinds
of stuff here I mean like you can like a
Krupa you can like see like things by in
this case I guess it's our like
advertiser poly ID you can see that
actually the the the Python workers are
already finishing and then you can see
that okay so like the number of events
per in like advertise about I guess I I
was like really polite and I actually
like removed like information that you
could use to compete with a troll so and
also I mean like you can just you wear a
net work equals Facebook that's all the
stuff that like Facebook is sending to
us and again I mean like takes a while
probably I mean it now needs to actually
generate an additional piece of code
that checks that the I mean this is
actually this line is has this like a
Facebook flag set and now I mean like it
has done the filtering and here are the
results
and then remember I mean like we have
like before it's really in rows here so
it's it's really a non-trivial amount of
data so yeah number works it works
pretty nicely and yeah that's it I'm
exactly on time so thank you
oh by the way yeah I mean like let me
just say this first so I mean like one
of the things when people ask me that
okay so white why I work at that role is
that like well I mean like first they're
companies like Facebook that have more
data so data is kind of exciting but if
you look at the data per engineer
headcount like ratio per day I mean it's
like it's it's really really pretty good
for us so yeah me we are hiring so yeah
so you said you it at some point it
generated some Python and it generates
it from what of a sequel where clause or
so actually how the foreign data repair
works in Postgres is that it gives you a
list of columns like in this case let me
show you like in this case what it would
like pass to us it would basically push
down the advertiser poly ID it would
push down the number of events it would
push down network and it says that okay
so these are the columns that are being
requested and and then like in this case
it would also say there like there is a
separate like I said of disk walls or
whatever qualifiers that say that okay
so the network has to be in Facebook and
that's kind of the data structure that
we get from post press and then we push
that down to our system and looked at
okay we need to generate a piece of code
that like retrieves the advertiser poly
ID number of events network and the
network name needs to equal Facebook's
okay so it's a it's a it's a set of
columns and maybe some constraints
exactly yeah thanks Bill I think we're
out of time actually one more questions
so I'm really interested in how how do
you keep your caches pumped if you're if
you're trying to keep your data in cache
like in l3 cache and also when you
launch these Python processes they seem
to come up pretty quickly if you removed
how much you're importing well I mean is
they just native Python because they
seem to just come up really quickly and
sometimes you know when I told you do
parallel things I try to keep them up
and running if possible but I mean like
here I mean like if you launch this
Python it takes yeah like like 10 I know
it's that like 10 milliseconds so I mean
launch in Python is really not that slow
but given given how long it took to do
the entire thing it was probably a
considerable portion of the time
compared to the i/o in memory and cached
yeah so well I mean well yeah I mean
like launching Python is one thing
there's some amount of like parsing that
needs to happen but that's that's really
really I mean like not that's
substantial the key part is that um it's
actually of course using memory mapping
do you like to kind of it bring the
encoded matrices in memory and like I'm
just like relying on the operating
system it will actually keep those pages
in memory as you query more frequently
the same page you'll keep an assistant -
yeah yeah I mean like that's the thing
you kind of want to be careful and like
about like with the operating system but
like it doesn't like come up with some
like a crazy idea that wants to kind of
like fold the pages or something and
actually it's also using the CPU pinning
so it's actually like a non-uniform
memory access machine so you don't want
the kind of kernel to kind of a keep
like moving two pages back and forth but
yeah I mean basically just a memory
mapping that's it and this is one
machine do you scale this type of query
across machines that's that's the beauty
of it and just imagining the kind of
thing the kind of a how little
operational pain there is to kind of run
a one machine instead of like a hive
cluster so yeah thank you